curiosity stream is the world's only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries featuring tons of amazing
titles you won't find on any other
streaming platforms get curiosity stream
for 25
off which is just 15 bucks a year by
clicking the link right underneath this
video
all right let's jump right in today with
some meaty policy we have so much to
talk about today california recall is
tonight we'll be streaming results live
we have a new tax proposal we have new
anti-vax mania we have all sorts of
different things but let's start with
some
policy
uh material from the democratic party
democrats are seeking uh to increase the
corporate tax as well as income tax on
the wealthy
to pay for this 3.5 trillion dollar plan
about which joe manchin is talking etc
etc so let's start with a report from
the associated press about the proposal
we will then look at it item by item and
then we will then look at some of the i
guess i would call it hyperbolic
panicked reporting about if you make 5
million and live in nyc you'll pay 60
total okay so let we'll go through it
piece by piece that's the way we like to
do it
uh house democrats unveiled a sweeping
proposal yesterday for tax hikes on big
corporations and the wealthy to fund joe
biden's 3.5 trillion dollar plan
the proposed top tax rate would revert
to 39.6 percent on individuals earning
more than 400 000 or 450 for couples
there would be a three percent tax on
wealthier americans with adjusted income
beyond 5 million a year for big
businesses the proposal would lift the
corporate tax rate from 21 to 26.5
percent
on incomes beyond 5 million slightly
less than the 28 percent rate the
president had sought
in all the tax hikes are in line with
biden's own proposals and would bring
about the most substantive changes in
the tax code since republicans with
then-president donald trump slashed
taxes in 2017. business and anti-tax
groups are sure to object but democrats
are pressing forward all right so
where do we start well what are the main
provisions of the bill and how do they
change from what we currently have so
let's look at it
the top tax bracket would in this on
individuals the top top tax bracket
would increase from 37 percent
to 39.6 percent this is that infamous
2.6 difference that democrats and
republicans have been arguing about for
a long time
remember
going from 37 to 39.6
that's back to the pre-bush top bracket
before bush the top tax rate was 39.6
under clinton
bush lowered it to 37.
obama let it go back up to 39.6 trump
went back down to 37. that's the scope
here okay it's a 2.6 percentage point
gap that is the subject of the argument
and the debate now
this the the wording has been muddy and
it's already been changed
the bracket would start lower right now
that top tax bracket doesn't kick in
until a couple makes 628 000 a year
together
under it appears as though
under the biden plan uh under the
democratic plan sorry the house
democrats plan that bracket would start
lower at 450 000
in joint income per year okay
there would be a three percent tax on
incomes over five million dollars a year
okay now it it's
you know with all of these things
there's always a question of how much
are you capturing by doing this there's
an argument to be made
that a lot of people who make a ton of
money
are not taking a salary
above five million dollars a year that a
lot of that would be
uh in stock options or in other types of
deferred compensation and it would avoid
that three percent tax but okay we'll
deal with that eventually
three percent tax on incomes over five
million a year and a corporate tax
increase
from 21
to 26 and a half percent only on incomes
beyond five million dollars now remember
uh this doesn't apply
to so many corporations llcs s
corporations etc because those are what
are called pass-through entities and the
income is taxed by the individual
stakeholders
on their personal income taxes so this
would apply
to a small portion of corporations and
remember if you're currently avoiding a
21
tax rate
you would then just go to avoiding a
26.5 tax rate unless
we put in place a corporate minimum tax
or some other mechanisms another issue
that we've talked about many times the
estimates are
this would raise about 2.9 trillion
dollars
of the 3.5 trillion dollars that the
legislation that is being discussed
would cost
all right now
there are some headlines that have been
floating
about you know in some states in some
cities with this proposal
individuals who make a lot of money
could end up paying around 60 for
example there's a cnbc our cnbc article
which says top earning new yorkers
that's new york city
could face a
61.2 percent combined tax rate under the
house plan californians could be paying
a 59 rate how could this be well let's
go through it first of all
you you would have to be at the top
level okay you'd have to be at that 5
million a year level
um and by the way if you're at 5 million
a year you actually don't pay the three
percent surcharge but let's because it
starts at 5 million but you could be in
new york city right you pay 39.6 on
income it's a marginal tax rate 3
surcharge
3.8 net investment income tax that would
get you to 46.4 and then if you're in
new york city you could have a combined
state income tax and city income tax of
14.8 you combine the 46 and the 14 and
it's 61.2 now that's not your effective
tax rate because remember these are
marginal tax rate it doesn't account for
the standard deduction other ways to
reduce tax liability but that's where
they're getting 61.2 is it exaggerated
yes are people who make that much
probably going to pay a lot more if this
passes yeah they probably will
but remember
that unless you're really bad with money
when you make more and more money
you're spending a smaller and smaller
share of your income i've said before
i'm very conservative financially i save
the vast majority of my income i don't
spend it i live well below my means so
if my income tax went up two three four
points
i'm saving less it's not actually
affecting my day-to-day budget and it's
important to understand that at these
super high levels if you're making 20
million a year
uh unless you're doing really bad
financial things
you're not even going to feel this now
you can still argue that it's too high
or that's a different argument but the
argument that
you know the vast majority of people
that are going to be affected by this
should not be spending anywhere near
what they make still can debate whether
this is quote right okay california
similar example you could have that 46.4
total federal
and then 13.3 state that would get you
to 59.7 in new jersey you could end up
at 57.2 hawaii 57.4
one other issue is we don't know whether
the limit on salt state and local tax
deductions is going to be removed um
this is just a proposal
and uh for people saying this is too
high people are going to move out of new
york city they're going to move out of
california the market will tell us you
know if it passes and people start
leaving new york city and california at
higher rates than people generally move
in and out then it will be a sign that
it's too high and remember that even if
people move out the state i'm sorry the
federal government or even the state
depending on you know what's going on
they could end up with more money
because there is
taxation is sort of on a curve
and you could raise taxes
and push out taxpayers but still take in
more money in total
um that's a that's just a broad you know
macroeconomic taxation concept here
we're talking about federal though and
important that this does nothing about
the multinationals that can use
different accounting tricks to book
revenue and profit in different
countries and to end up losing money on
paper in the united states this won't
change that you would need a total
revamp
and of course this is only a proposal
we're going to follow where it goes
not shockingly much of the controversy
around vaccine requirements is
dramatically exaggerated by people
looking to get attention people looking
to fundraise people looking to
fearmonger people looking to play the
victim card
most americans support vaccine
requirements for workplaces classrooms
and sporting events period just a
majority when i say most i mean a
majority now i don't say this because i
think that just because something is
popular it should be the law
i don't
there was a point where a lot of people
thought gay marriage shouldn't be legal
that didn't mean that that's what it
should be
uh you don't put everything to a vote
but i say this because there is not
nearly the controversy over vaccine
requirements that some want you to
believe there is so the numbers from a
new cnn poll
uh overall for everyday activities
only 51 percent favor versus 49 oppose
vaccine requirements that's a very very
small it's basically within the margin
of error 50 50. but when you say what
about vaccine requirements for places of
work 54 are in favor the other 46 are
split between against and being unsure
54 say
vaccines should be required for places
of work 55 say vaccines should be
required for in-person classes
55 say vaccines should be required for
sporting events or concerts
comparatively only 41 say vaccines
should be required for the grocery store
that's predictable that that's the
that's not shocking to me
also every month that this poll is done
support for these vaccine requirements
goes up and i anticipate that the
numbers will be even higher in terms of
support for these vaccine requirements
in another month so this is not
overwhelming support it's not like after
sandy hook with universal background
checks 88 90 of the country said we need
universal background checks we still
couldn't get it done by the way but it's
a slight majority whereas right-wing
media would have you believe this is
tyranny over which the entire country is
outraged that's just not the case
part of the reason why support continues
to increase for these requirements is
that the virus is spreading and things
are really really bad in much of the
country if everyone were vaccinated it
would effectively reduce the total
public health burden of covid
down to about the level of the flu
we don't have that the unvaccinated are
burdening the healthcare system to such
a degree
that there's very little choice left but
for joe biden to try these ideas this
sort of spreading anti-vaxxerism that
has infected so many is a virus of
itself it's its own infection and let's
be honest when we say more than half the
country supports most of these
requirements
it's mostly democrats
a fair number of independents and a very
small number of republicans public
health
has become partisan science has become
partisan you don't like the science
pretend that science is just an opinion
and come up with a different one that's
a real tragedy that we're experiencing
and unfortunately although we're dealing
with it to a far greater degree degree
than most other countries it's actually
starting to infect some other countries
as well and we're going to talk more
about that a little bit later on in the
program let me know if you favor
vaccine requirements for work
concerts
grocery stores you can find me on
twitter at dpakman and let me know your
thoughts
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the only subscription streaming service
that focuses exclusively on
documentaries if you love documentaries
the way i do you're missing out if you
don't have a subscription to curiosity
stream i love it for one reason it has
the biggest best selection of
documentaries that you'll find anywhere
including the newest popular ones that
everybody's talking about and most of it
is stuff you really can't find on other
streaming services last month they added
a ton of great new documentaries to the
library one i watched is brimstone and
glory
about a pyrotechnic festival in mexico
random but fascinating curiosity stream
is giving my audience 25 percent off
which means you can subscribe for just
15 bucks a year not a big price tag for
the hours and hours of enjoyment i know
you will get from curiositystream just
go to curiositystream.com
pacman25 the link is underneath this
video
we have so much to cover today that i
will take only the minimum amount of
time to remind you that we are funded by
memberships and you can get a membership
at joinpacman.com today only
use the coupon code no recall
no recall in california that's what
we're talking about the california
gubernatorial recall is today you'll get
a 70 discount um at joinpakman.com no
recall that's the code all one word all
lowercase okay i have video of death
cult republican governor ron desantis
he defiantly
and courageously has announced no matter
what joe biden says about vaccine
requirements and what employers should
do
in florida
if you as an employer require
vaccination
you will be fined five thousand dollars
this guy is going backwards on just
about everything the crowd cheering we
have clips we have conspiracies we have
everything let's get right into it this
is ron desantis yesterday
saying
vaccine requirement fines
not vaccine requirements
fines for vaccine requirements here we
go
and so if a government agency in the
state of florida
forces a vaccine as a condition to
employment that violates florida law and
you will face
now you know sycophantic cheering aside
this is really muddled because the biden
requirement is for employers over a
hundred employees desantis is talking
about state government agencies
requiring it to work now the biden
version has an opt-out which just
requires a weekly test so it's not even
really clear that this is a direct
response to the biden requirements it's
just the desantis mess
and you will face a 5 000 fine for every
single violation okay so this is um
you know the the party that says
never regulate business business should
be allowed
they are now starting to say no let's
actually regulate business in this case
talking about state government agencies
rather than businesses but he's been
pulling a lot of the very same stuff
then going on to talk about
um
booster shots so-called booster shots
some calling them third doses and again
just so hyperbolic so sycophantic here
we go can you imagine if trump had
unilaterally
set a date for fda without their having
underlying data i mean the corporate
press would have a meltdown i mean it
would be
wall-to-wall hysteria now remember joe
biden talking about september 20th is
the date at which people will be able to
go and get third doses
be able to go
and the idea that there's anything
tyrannical about that is just as silly
as the idea that there's anything
tyrannical about any of the things that
have been done so far him perverting
science and not following experts or
whatever and look i have no knowledge
because i've not seen any data about
these booster shots but it could be in a
situation where what six months from now
if fauci says get one you just have to
do it are they gonna fire you then at
that point are they gonna fire you a
year from now okay um ron desantis then
continuing on and then
giving us some scenario about forcing an
80 year old to be vaccinated pinning
down an 80 year old you know there were
some that just did not want to take it
they did not think that it was something
that was right for them and so what are
you going to do you going to pin down
some 80 year old nursing home resident
and forced them to take it they had
whatever reason i don't know what what
the reasons were whether a doctor
recommended whether they had covered
before what have you and so it just
shows that um and i also think that what
they're doing is very harmful yeah um
this guy's completely out of his mind i
mean it is a death cult of sorts i don't
even know quite frankly that desantis
believes this stuff
i think he knows he's playing to a cult
in florida and he'll be punished if he
doesn't do this stuff here's a clip i
actually can't tell if this was the same
event or not
let's see look he's wearing the same
suit
although it might be no i guess it it's
the same room the lighting is different
here
an anti-vaxxer was invited to speak
stood behind the seal of florida
and said the vaccine changes your rna it
doesn't and desantis just stands there
the vaccine changes your rna so for me
that's a problem
so i i'm here with you folks um we don't
want to have the the vaccine it's it's
about our freedom and liberty it's not
about the vaccine yeah
so i mean okay desantis looked a little
bit uncomfortable with that but when he
spoke he just thanked the guy and did
not mention anything about the fact that
the vaccine does not change your rna
does not change your rna i don't even
think the guy's speaking knows what that
means so a complete death cult
continuing to control florida
unfortunately
let's make sure that a similar death
cult doesn't take control of california
by voting no on that recall tonight
okay this is really great stuff a
question i've been asking for weeks now
is
if you are opposed to the approved
covid19 vaccine being required anywhere
why aren't you opposed to a requirement
for the chickenpox vaccine
or the polio
or mmr
or hepatitis or whatever the case may be
fox news host chris wallace confronted
the republican
nebraska governor pete ricketts about
exactly that question now ricketts is
again
uh
loudly coming out against everything joe
biden is trying to do on coronavirus
requirements including most recently the
vaccine mandates and requirements for
employers and others but the very same
pete ricketts is fine with tons of other
vaccines this is fascinating stuff let's
watch and listen to the multiple things
that ricketts says because we're going
to break them down one by one in a
moment to attend school in your state of
nebraska children must be vaccinated
against a number of diseases let me put
them up on the screen
they must be vaccinated against
diphtheria
tetanus and pertussis that's the dtp
shot that kids get
polio measles mumps and rubella
hepatitis b and chickenpox
why
are those mandates that parents in your
state must comply with
and do comply with routinely
why is it that they're not
so objectionable and such a violation
beautiful personal freedom but biden's
vaccine mandates are
well for all those that you just listed
there's a long history that parents have
had the opportunity to see how those
things have been implemented
so there's a long history is not
actually an argument it might sound like
an argument but it's not actually an
argument he's not explaining why that
should matter maybe if he tried to
explain he could give us something
substantive and we might be convinced or
not but alone that's not an argument and
there's still a lot of people out there
who don't know what to trust and in fact
this is really an outcome of what the
cdc has done because they flip-flop on
so many issues whether it's mass or
whether you have to mask after vaccine
and so forth okay so then he says lots
of people don't know who to trust
that's also not an argument because the
question is in either case with all the
vaccines they're approved by the same
body
and then the cdc has flip-flopped
this one i'm very sick of they act like
when the cdc changes their view based on
more data
they act like it's just changing your
mind about a movie you like i mean
listen one day you like the movie you're
in a different mood the next day you
don't like it the cdc uses science which
is a process with with a self-correcting
mechanism built in it becomes ideally
more accurate over time and it's not an
argument against one vaccine but not
another remember the question was
why is this vaccine requirement not okay
and that one is so it it's in particular
not not an argument against that there's
just a lot of people out there who don't
know who to trust right now and so by
having the government force it on you're
not building a trust where we have the
trust with those other vaccines now
remember it's also not being forced your
employer can choose to let people test
out each week instead of being
vaccinated or not if your employer
doesn't want to
as republicans like pete ricketts want
employers to be able to do
this is a process going to take time to
bring people along and that's why it
should be a personal choice and not
something mandated by the government but
but forgive me sir i'm old enough that i
remember when the polio vaccine first
came out uh a lot of us and certainly
our parents viewed it as a blessing and
immediately i lived in new york state at
that time the state mandated that we all
get the polio vaccine right so you know
we're in the middle of a pandemic there
is a new vaccine that donald trump was
largely responsible for it's been
approved full approval by the fda
again if if
polio vaccine is okay for for parents
and they have to comply with it to send
their kid to school why not chris
wallace is doing a good job here for
a lot of people not just kids
the vaccine for uh for this disease
yeah i think this is very different from
polio that has very devastating effects
and certainly we know if you're older
you know 65 years and older that's where
83 percent of our deaths in nebraska so
then he drops in well polio is
devastating well then talk about another
condition i mean the the death rate of
chickenpox is really low it's one per
100 thousand
if you look at slightly older kids it's
six per 100 thousand it's very
contagious
but it's not very deadly so the point
here is he has no good answer and this
is a question we've been asking for a
while look at all these other
requirements for vaccination they're
only talking of most 99.9 of them are
only talking about the covid vaccine
requirement they are pathetic they don't
have an answer that they're able to
articulate if they can come up with an
actual substantive explanation
i would gladly review it and think about
it and maybe they will convince me okay
before we go to break i do want to
squeeze in just one other one of these
stories
um it really appears as though being a
right-wing radio host
and or
a right-wing pastor can be very very
dangerous bob enyart
conservative fire brand and pastor
big anti-vaxx
dies of covet 19.
the denver post is reporting that the
pastor of the denver bible church and
indelible talk show host
has died from covid
bob enyart was one of the smartest and
without question wisest person i've
known said fred williams his co-host on
the real science radio show
real science can you imagine enyart and
his wife refused to get the vaccine due
to abortion concerns
in october enyart successfully sued the
state over mass mandates and capacity
limits in churches a rare legal victory
against public health mandates
instituted during the pandemic
um you might be saying abortion what
what are you what are you talking about
i checked out the uh website
and they have a section covet vaccines
uh where they say this is from last
month guys guys dead now
bob and cheryl have sworn off taking the
pfizer moderna and johnson vaccines
because as those firms admit they tested
the three products on the cells of
aborted babies
there are however vaccines being
developed morally though none are
scheduled to be available until the end
of this year our friends over at
cog4life.org list these coming ethical
vaccines
merck sanofi and from novavax
the charlotte lozier institute reports
innovo and bioentech are also producing
vaccines developed without fetal tissue
so while it is not inherently sinful to
take an immorally developed vaccine
we urge everyone to boycott pfizer
moderna and johnson
to further increase social tension wow
and put pressure on the child killers
remember many institutions and
celebrities who have been pro-choice all
along are now calling to legalize
infanticide
which they call after birth abortion so
there's no bottom to their abyss
sanofi pastor has discontinued using
fetal tissue for the polio vaccine well
so maybe soon they'll allow people to
get the polio vaccine at this church
these people are causing death he died
he died now another one of these guys
who died but they are also causing death
elsewhere uh by convincing people of
this stuff so another
anti-vaxx radio host who is also a
pastor
just last week saying no pfizer no
modern no no johnson as they call it um
he has now died
uh
what can you say what can you say we'll
have more on that
on our instagram
at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
tim jackson who's an ecological
economist professor and also author of
the book post growth life after
capitalism it's so great to have you on
i appreciate it
it's a it's a pleasure to be here david
so let's start with something that to a
social democrat like me
uh is still something that is in the
back of my mind which is that we are on
a planet that
has some maximum capacity in terms of
resources in terms of population
carrying capacity etc
uh our economies are based on
a little bit of inflation is good and
where that inflation comes from is the
expectation that there will be more
productivity in the future than there is
today and gdp
has to continue going up or we consider
that we're in a recession
structurally at some point that becomes
a problem right is that a sound place to
start the conversation
yeah i think it is a sound place to
start the conversation david and it's
definitely where i start as well um and
and it's surprising
it's surprisingly easy to kind of make
that argument you know to to ordinary
people in the streets in a way we're
living on a finite planet the economy is
supposed to expand forever we're told by
economists surely at some point you know
um expanding economy into finite planet
doesn't go
so so what nurse is going on and and
um
what's surprising i think is that that's
a difficult proposition for
politicians of any color i would say
to really take seriously or to know what
to do anything about um
and and economists typically i would
have to say tend to think that uh
that the economy is is about money it's
not necessarily about stuff
um and so if we're clever enough with
our technology we can sort of get
ourselves off the hook
and work our way around all of these
resource limits and i suppose
you know that's an argument right and so
one of the arguments that's frequently
made is
while what you're saying is true at this
point it's basically theoretical in the
sense that it's very far out and you
know a hundred years ago nobody could
have predicted exactly the way things
are today if we're talking thousands or
tens of thousands of years from now
things will be so structurally different
that this is at minimum going to at
in the best case it will resolve itself
in the worst case we'll have the tools
with which to deal with it by the time
it's really a problem but that doesn't
really seem satisfying as as
an ecological answer
well i think i think where it falls down
too
is that that might be true for some
kinds of resources that we might run out
of but actually we're already running
out of what you could call ecological
space you know we're running out of
climate stability we're running out of
the other species on the planet that are
being decimated because of human
activity we're running out of clean
water and clean air and clean oceans and
and that running out is actually
something that's happening right now i
mean the evidence on that is alarming
just uh simply the climate change uh
evidence what what's faced you know the
west coast in terms of heat and the east
coast in terms of of flooding and europe
in terms of flooding and australia in
terms of heat almost everywhere you look
on the planet you know we're seeing
these extreme weather conditions which
suggest that
you know somehow
that far out scenario that expanding
economy meets the limits of the planet
actually isn't that far out after all
it's kind of right here on our doorstep
one of the um
issues i guess that economists are
confronted with within this kind of
conversation within this paradigm is
there are certain aspects of how we
think about an economy that are kind of
taken for granted i mentioned already if
gdp isn't growing this is a country that
is stagnating or in a recession in a
decline that's one aspect of this
debt and deficit and how that relates to
how
a country is doing is is a big piece of
this
how would those metrics
have to be completely rethought under
the umbrella and framework that you
propose
well i think i think in a way you know
gdp was never a very good metric i mean
one of the things i do in the book is go
back to the words of of of robert
kennedy speaking in 1968 53 years ago
where actually he was a you know
prominent politician prepared to
acknowledge the limits of this measure
of the gdp and say look it measures
um you know
everything
except that which makes life worthwhile
he said but it also it misses out the
damage we're causing to the planet it
doesn't include
the positive things that people do for
free in their own homes it's just not a
very good measure
of our well-being and and so so in a
sense you know the answer to your
question well let's start with some
better measures of what really matters
and some of those measures you know like
uh uh our sense of well-being and our
sense of purpose and so on could be
could be measures which are very
unfamiliar to politicians and that's a
little bit of a challenge but others of
them are really quite simple like you
know not measuring for example how much
we are degrading our capital assets in
the economy itself is something that the
gdp is is um notorious for for for
failing to do
and and not putting any sort of sense of
cost on um on the damage that we're
causing to
to the environment and not putting any
sort of value on the the work that
people do in their own homes
all of these things actually and there
are very very good uh
attempts to improve that measure of the
gdp but you could almost say at this
point in time
almost any distance towards measuring
something more meaningful than the gdp
would be a step forwards because it's
just not a very good measure of progress
it's not a very good measure of human
progress in society so in terms of some
of those things
um the universal basic income movement
which has different names proposes
itself as a way to put value to that
which is done in the home for example or
that which an economy may not currently
value
uh carbon carbon taxes would be a way in
which we might put a monetary value on
the degradation or of the environment or
the pollution that that's released et
cetera
is that thinking too small still or are
those good ideas good steps no they are
very good ideas and some you know in
some ways something like universal basic
income is and i think when you know one
of the architects of the universal basic
income andre gortz talking about it
first
or or talking about it seriously in the
1960s he wasn't the first person to talk
about it but but what he sort of said
was it's a sort of stealth concept
because by changing our relationship to
the way that we earn money and by
changing our relationship to the way
that we work it enables us to think in
massively creative ways about all the
valuable things that are happening in
society like you know kind of
volunteering in our community and the
free work that happens in the home and
looking after our elderly and looking
after our kids and it allows us to put a
value on those things which
in the
purely capitalist system in the system
of the market if you like just don't
have that value on them so i you know
i'm in favor of those but i still think
i mean to answer your question
i would say they are tools in a toolbox
um and
the the difficulty sometimes in
implementing those tools using those
tools is that the architects of the
system
don't allow them to be used so the
example of ecological taxation for
example we talked about for decades and
yet it's really hard to implement
because of the politics of a
growth-based economy well that that's
where i was going to go next which is
when we talk about you know convincing
people getting people on board etc
it seems that two four and six-year
political terms in in you know a variety
of different countries
are completely mismatched with the
timeline and priorities that are
required to deal with these issues where
a lot of these things
are longer term projects and if your
next election is in two years or four or
six
it just seems to be fundamentally at
odds with the time scales that we're
talking about to actually make some of
these structural changes
it's it is at odds in many ways and i
think you know that's not the only thing
that's wrong with the political system
because the other thing that's wrong is
it becomes
in some sense because of the way
in which political parties become funded
uh they end up being a sort of apologist
for the status quo of defending invested
interests and that sometimes stands in
the way of them uh representing the
interests of the poorest in society the
most vulnerable in society including of
course the other species we share the
planet with so you we do have to think
much more seriously i think about you
know the role of of governance and the
role of power
within government and and think about
that as you're suggesting in with a much
longer term view
and again there are some interesting
initiatives there
um that in hungary there's something
called the ombudsman for future
generations a kind of representative of
people who are coming way down the line
from the future and are not represented
by the democracy of the day and that's
been taken up in wales in the uk
um
with a future generations act and
there's so this initiative in fact to
change the way that government works to
bring the future into our decision
making in the present is a really
important part of of thinking about how
we address those long-term issues
certainly part of this would also be
more citizens
demanding these things of elected
officials
and there are a lot of
sort of
bullet points that are often repeated by
those who don't want to take these
issues more seriously about how such
structural change would impact our
day-to-day lives things about
you know you might only be able to have
small cars in the united states or
gas might be twenty dollars a gallon or
you might not be able to use your air
conditioning whenever you want or really
a lot of this day-to-day stuff
um
at the personal level what would a
paradigm shift the likes of which you
propose really mean for individuals
yeah that's a really good question i
mean i my work over over through more
than three decades now has been really
working in policy and it's been about
you know suggesting the kinds of
economic policies that would that would
address some of these issues and in fact
just over 10 years 12 years ago the
previous book that uh that i wrote was
called prosperity without growth it was
written for policymakers it had all of
these wonderful ideas you know like
ecological tax reform universal basic
income different ways of valuing the
environment different ways of measuring
well-being it had all that stuff in it
almost like a you know kind of shopping
list for what politicians could do on
monday if they really cared about this
issue right and it's been fascinating to
see that not happen
and and you know it doesn't happen for
all sorts of reasons vested interests
short political time scales that we
talked about but also that fear
within politics that the electorate will
not stand for this kind of change you
know they they it's a it's a hard tough
place to be in which our lives will
become
less comfortable more arduous and so on
and so forth so the kind of language of
fear that populates this debate
and in a way what i was trying to do in
post-grace was to say that's a mistake
you know the fear that we should have
actually
is of an economy that doesn't respect
the environment that doesn't respect
the value of human labor in our lives
that doesn't value these things properly
at all and that is driving us towards
you know a divided
world in which our environmental
resources are being degraded at a rate
we can't we can't cope with anymore
that's where dystopia lies and so the
postgres is really about looking for
where
an escape route from dystopia might
exist and i you know i think that that's
led me across philosophy it's led me
across psychology it's led me across
politics and and and indeed you know
moral thinking thinking about about the
ethics of our world and the thing that
leaps out at me i think most clearly
from that is that this the potential for
for human development for human progress
outside of this very materialistic
consumer-based
growth-driven economy that we've
inherited
is huge it's massive
because at the end of the day um you
know the kind of world in which i think
we thrive
is one in which our relationships are
strong in which our community feels
secure
a world in which our work is not just
you know good in terms of income and
keeping us going but it's meaningful as
it has purpose for us and that and that
sense actually of living in a world in
which there is
hope for the future because we're taking
those environmental limits seriously is
a tremendously creative place and i've
been fascinated in particular by ideas
from within psychology which sort of
suggests that actually
somehow materialism and the comfort of
consumerism
stand in the way of us
making real human progress they stand in
the way of us developing skills because
because we come to become too lazy they
stand in the way of us developing active
active lives because we can't become too
comfortable and sit around eating too
much and being comfortable being
comfortable is wonderful you know don't
get me wrong i'm not knocking being
comfortable but there's a sense in which
being outside of that comfort zone takes
us to
our true potential as human beings where
we learn those skills where we engage in
activities that give us satisfaction
where we feel as though we're embodied
in a world in which we have meaning and
purpose and in which there is hope for
the future and to me
therefore you know where i came out of
that exploration is really that this
post-growth world is a is a richer
place to be
not necessarily in terms of money
definitely not necessarily in terms of
material possessions but in terms of our
capabilities to live truly
uh fulfilling lives as human beings and
to return to ourselves that sense
of hope in the future yep and of course
the challenges in the midst of consumer
culture that bombards people it's
getting people to even be open to the
idea that that may actually be richer
and more fulfilling certainly an uphill
battle uh the book is i think
yeah no just on that point david i mean
i think that's true
and yet there are a million places to
start with that right you know how how
we dr how we educate our kids how we
think about our own progression through
life yeah what decisions we make about
where we invest our money and our time
all of those are places to start so
although
you know there are a lot as you say
there are lots of obstacles to that to
making those kinds of choices there are
also
there's a myriad of opportunities for
making them as well well well said well
said uh the book is post growth life
after capitalism we've been speaking
with tim jackson i so appreciate your
time today
it's been a pleasure david
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show okay let's talk about
the california gubernatorial recall the
california gubernatorial recall is today
there are basically two possibilities
either the don't recall the keep gavin
newsom side wins
and gavin newsom remains the democratic
governor of california an overwhelmingly
democratic state or or or
the remove
gavin newsome side wins and almost
certainly an outrageous right-wing
extremist named larry elder
becomes the pro-trump
anti-vaxx anti-mask
governor
of california really horrible stuff
we'll get to how it's looking in a
moment last night joe biden actually was
in california and he did an event in
support of gavin newsom ron philipkowski
doing a great job with his team covering
the riff raff outside the event he has
teams at all of these different events
filming check out this this is just to
give you like the flavor of what's going
on
this is just another argument between
you know there's anti-vaxxers there
there's all sorts of wacky people
showing up and just listen to the
arguments that are taking place here if
you
can't a
californian by the public school system
notice what's going on here there's two
different arguments going on in front of
an f joe biden sign it's it's just
complete and total chaos
you guys following the disagreement here
in less than one year
now the audio glitched but i think air
force mom unmasked air force mom
is yelling that there have been hundreds
of thousands of deaths from the vaccine
i think is that what she's saying less
than one year they're not happening
do you know how many people die from the
crew you're you're busy
died from the vaccine in one year have
you looked it up she's saying more
people died from the vaccine than the
flu i guess
that's where you've been indoctrinated
that's where your brain washed because
not everybody dies dies of covet honey
not everybody dies of province covenant
has a 99 survival rate why do i know
vaccines
so that's air force mom screaming there
the proud boys also had a presence at
this event this is a short clip uh if
you're not watching the the the proud
boys are
you know walking with a huge banner it's
just all it's all nuts
[Music]
[Applause]
the banner says free all political
prisoners now which is a reference
basically they're saying free all of the
rioters who were arrested on january 6th
they want those they want the
insurrectionists freedom
[Applause]
are they saluting now what are they
doing
there's a police line
someone just yelled communists there
man these are the last places i would be
caught it's just it's crazy then they
went back to air force mom like a while
later and the argument was still going
on with anti-vaxx air force mom here's
what america growing up to do do your
research
sociological experiment so if you've
just been listening to these people
arguing
on the left slash kind of like in the
background
you've got unmasked unvaccinated air
force mom telling a woman
that more people died from the vaccine
than from the flu in the last year
that's of course not true
then in the foreground you have another
woman
saying that the gavin newsom t if gavin
newsom stays in
the taxes will break california now
remember
um california has one of the most
dynamic economies in the world if
california were a country it would be
growing almost as quickly as many really
quickly growing developing nations
there's a homelessness problem without a
doubt it's not affordable for everyone
but one of the things that makes places
expensive is demand people want to be
there and it drives the prices of things
up so two wacky arguments happening at
the exact same time
illegal immigrants have more rights than
we do illegal immigrants have more
rights than so the xenophobia gets
thrown in too
or
okay well but how much do you make what
percentage is that okay so the important
thing is the recall is today today today
today if you haven't voted yet you've
got to vote mail in that ballot the good
news is that after in early august it
was basically tied okay it was basically
tied in early august
gavin newsom has built a lead that is
now
16 points now does that mean we don't
vote of course not it means you've got
to go vote you've got to go vote results
are expected around 8 p.m california
time tonight tonight 11 p.m eastern time
i will be streaming i will be streaming
up until we get those first results and
i hope that you will join me
uh unfortunately unfortunately or maybe
predictably
larry elder the republican can't the
leading republican candidate
is not
committed to accepting the results if he
loses let's talk about that next
this should really come as absolutely no
surprise to any of us but the leading
republican gov gubernatorial recall
candidate in the california
gubernatorial recall
is not saying he will accept the results
and in fact seems to have already
conceded defeat and has launched an
initiative to say that we need to
recount or something like that the daily
beast is reporting larry elder
preemptively concedes defeat and
launches a voter fraud site
before the results of today's california
gubernatorial recall have even come in
top polling republican candidate larry
elder appeared to be already conceding
defeat on monday and preparing to blame
his loss on baseless claims of
widespread voter fraud as first reported
by the sacramento bee
elder's campaign launched a website
calling for his supporters to report
incidents of voter fraud and sign a
petition to investigate the results wait
hold on you're calling for an
investigation before the results are out
the site which is paid for by the
campaign includes language that assumes
governor newsom has already won although
no results have yet been released and
elder is campaigning
the site says quote we implore you to
join us in this fight as you are able
primarily by signing our petition
demanding a special session of the
california legislature to investigate
and ameliorate the twisted results of
this recall wait we don't have the
results yet you're calling for
for some kind of
uh investigation of the results that we
don't yet have
it goes on to say additionally the
website states statistical analyses used
to detect fraud in elections held in
third world nations such as russia
venezuela and iran have detected fraud
in california resulting in governor
newsom being reinstated as governor by
the way reinstated he was never removed
it's all crazy and it really shouldn't
surprise us here was larry elder
yesterday being asked multiple times
will you commit to accepting the results
and he won't say that he will because he
obviously will not
larry elder the leading republican
candidate would not commit to accepting
the results of the election yeah
again whether or not you win or lose
will you accept the results of the
election tomorrow no i think we all
ought to be looking at election
integrity no matter whether you're a
democrat an independent or a republican
let's all make sure that the election is
a fair election until this all work
together no matter sir do you have any
reason to believe that it is not fair as
of right now do you have any evidence
what the results are to make sure that
the results are valid and legitimate and
everybody who voted should have voted
let's all do that together is that a
commitment to accept the results of the
election tomorrow let's all do that
together let's all work together uh on
both sides of the aisle to make sure
that the election is a fair election
yeah i would like to see the actual
question
is there anything right now that you can
point to that makes you doubt the
integrity of this election donald trump
i mean it shouldn't surprise us larry
elder is doing this i played for you
this clip last week donald trump on
newsmax is already saying it's rigged in
california as the polling has gone more
and more in favor of gavin newsom
the claims of rigging have increased
got the recall election coming up in
less than a week it's actually happening
as we speak the polls appear to show
newsome looks safer at this point larry
elder is the man that could take it from
him what do you think happens in
california
well it's probably rigged they're
sending out all ballots it's all uh the
the ballots are you know mail out
mail-in ballots in fact i guess you even
have a case where you can make your own
ballot when that happens uh in crayon
you can make your own ballot nobody's
going to win except uh these democrats
so you know look they're very good the
one thing they're good at is rigging
elections so i predict it's a rigged
election let's see how it turns out so
there is of course no evidence of that
whatsoever but they are already claiming
fraud already claiming fraud
let's hope that uh
larry elder does not become the governor
of california it would be a real tragedy
i see it as a partial referendum on
trumpism elder a big pro-trump guy big
big pro-trump guy
um and keeping newsome would not only be
better for california than putting in
larry elder
who says there should be no minimum wage
he i mean listen i can't we went through
the whole list on a stream yesterday um
and has said he would end any kind of
mass requirements any kind of vaccine
requirements end everything and trump's
great
um
let's hope that that doesn't happen
tonight you can join me live on youtube
twitch and facebook
for results from california tonight okay
we have a voicemail number that number
is
david p
here's a very good question
and i'm going to be honest with you
about the answer okay listen to the
question then i'll give you my answer
hi david this is david from ohio
i was just wondering if trump was still
president
would more people be taking the vaccine
would everyone be taking the vaccine
would we be better off as a country
i was just wondering your thoughts on
that
thanks
listen
yes
it is undeniable
that if donald trump were president
right now
more americans would be vaccinated there
is no question because the people who
follow science who are vaccinated today
would still be vaccinated if trump were
president
but there would be millions of trumpists
who have not gotten the vaccine because
it has been joe biden overseeing its
rollout
who would have gotten vaccinated if
trump were president now the second
question is tougher would we be better
off as a country
that's harder to say because trump was
such an unmitigated unmitigated disaster
i think
long term we're better off with joe
biden rather than trump
even though you would have more trump is
vaccinated if trump were president but i
fully admit
the people that care about rhetoric
rather than science
they would likely be vaccinated at a
much higher rate if trump were president
today if you disagree with me let me
know but i don't think i think i would
be lying to you if i denied that we have
a great bonus show for you today
september 18th saturday might be trump
riots number two we will talk about the
measures security measures that police
are taking in dc in advance of that
corporations tried to blame individuals
for the plastic crisis oh you got to
recycle that bottle
now states are starting to turn the
tables on corporations and salesforce is
offering to relocate texas-based
employees on the basis of the texas
abortion law
very interesting what salesforce is
doing we will talk about all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
curiosity stream is the world's only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries featuring tons of amazing
titles you won't find on any other
streaming platforms get curiosity stream
for 25 off which is just 15 bucks a year
by clicking the link right underneath
this video